I was like fake religious growing up
like I wanted to have saved sex till
marriage so I had sex before marriage
anyways so
I had sex like right before College like
when I was 18. that's a light blooming
that's pretty lame anal because that
doesn't count oh because you're a good
Catholic girl yeah
wait so was that enjoyable for you I
felt like for me it was just shitty nice
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have Kazumi in the
hot tea
yeah
so the way these hot tea episodes work
is that we progressively ask you hot and
harder questions as we go forward but we
always start with Bart who begins with
the coldest possible question
like a cold question yeah real cold if
a caterpillar
can turn into any other animal with any
any
and why I would like a caterpillar to
turn into wagyu and then I would eat it
is
[Laughter]
it goes straight into being on a skewer
and then you [ __ ] roast it yeah yeah
it becomes like my Wagyu steak can you
imagine if it became like the most like
tenderloin
look at the marbling on that that's
actually one of the best answers we've
had be [ __ ] collecting caterpillars
all day and then he's just like come on
I start a [ __ ] caterpillar [ __ ]
business food is um like shabu-shabu so
I always eat black people just had
yesterday
dude I could lose
Xbox could have my fine like my whole
retirement fund oh I've never been there
the wagon spot in Vegas yeah that [ __ ]
is crazy you know it's good it's really
good yeah that's probably like the best
expot like Shabu Shabu spot damn what's
Shabu Shabu it's like let's go I like it
guys
you had Korean barbecue right well you
make your grill your own meat so instead
of grilling it it's boiling it and you
put vegetables and [ __ ] you make your
own soup oh wait I've had that like it's
like it's a Japanese show yeah yeah I've
had that speaking of shopping
um how many is the number what do you
mean that you've had sex with what oh
your total body count total body count
one bajillion
do you keep track you don't no I don't
keep you you lose count problems I
wouldn't know and also it's like there's
so many different types of sex like I've
had sex with a lot of women and
obviously like women like after oral sex
it's like okay yeah I would count that
because I've had great sex with women
and then there's also like times where
it's like if I'm [ __ ] bro and then
this guy like holds my leg up is that a
threesome I don't know like it's like
because he touched your ankle yeah yeah
and then is that two people now or let's
participating and what if he like
touches my boob now it's a threesome
like and what if this guy's like I'm
just jacking off yeah I'll I'll count it
for you okay so we'll make an Excel
sheet and then so for this is how I
count very sexy I don't count hookers
what I will count hookers why I'm
putting it in there to count Joe's like
[ __ ] my body counts High
yeah on her system I [ __ ] less than a
handful of maybe 10 two handful of
hookers okay
and then there's some people that like I
just dry humped that counts then there's
some people I say I love you no dry home
though
but like what if penetration sex
what if I didn't come that still counts
oh that's still sex yo it still sex it's
not fun sex but yeah exactly it's not
fun give me a head that doesn't count
that's whack that's that should not be
counted that's whack yeah whack it
doesn't count question for you um when
did you lose your virginity my virginity
yeah
um I felt like I I've said this in a
bunch of podcasts but I was I was like
fake religious growing up like I wanted
to have saved sex till marriage so I had
sex before marriage anyways
so I had sex like right before College
like when I was 18. but before pretty
late he's doing anal because that
doesn't count oh you would know because
you're a good Catholic girl yeah
wait so was that enjoyable for you I
felt like for me it was just shitty
nice I felt like it was a cool
experience you know but at the time I
felt like I was able to really get to
know guys in Intimate ways as we figured
out how to have fun with each other
without having been penetrative so she's
like you give a hand job here a [ __ ]
yeah I was good at foreplay and then we
would just put it in the butt and then I
would poop all over it and then I would
say sorry and then he'd be like it's
okay and then we would go on our ways
yeah so you kind of oopsy had a poopsie
you'll see it it sounds like you eased
into stuff like you didn't just go full
on a lot of people he's right in the
anal yeah I actually know a lot of girls
that done anal first before because of
that scene it literally doesn't count I
will die by this if I died right before
I lost my virginity I would have went to
heaven but now I will go to hell for
sure so when did you start doing anal
then that was probably
like like senior year of high school
that's still Late Bloomer yeah but I had
a lot of but I had a boyfriend from like
13 to 17. and we only would get up to
oral you know damn you gotta yeah yeah
and that's not discipline you could stop
yourself I just felt like at the time I
also felt like sex was like I had like
weirder opinions about sex like I felt
like sex had to mean something every
single time like I remembered it was
this extremely like important part of my
life it was it was to the same guy I
lost my butt sex but like I remember he
was like let's make out and I was like
nah and he was like he was like but do
you want to make out I was like I do
want to make out but I don't want to
feel but with my butthole but I was like
but I don't want to feel like a [ __ ] you
know because we're not dating you're not
my boyfriend and he was like we
literally don't have to be dating to
make out we don't even have to be
[ __ ] to do it like you we don't need
to be dating you could just do things
because you want to not because you're
you care about other people's experience
or opinions on you you it's like totally
separate what a Confucius and that like
definitely like in a weird way he's like
let's [ __ ] without any strings attached
yeah cause I was just like
just like try to not have sexual
experiences because they don't want to
bring their body count up or they don't
want to feel like a [ __ ] because they're
just like but it's like dude I'm young
and I want to experience my sexuality
and like I want to explore it and as
long as this person respects me honestly
if I want to make out this guy I'm gonna
make out of this guy and if I want to
have butt sex with this guy I'm gonna
have butt sex with this guy and everyone
can know and it doesn't that's a t-shirt
yeah
it doesn't matter what other people
think about it you know and I feel like
a lot of women try to keep their body
count low or not
it's like then you don't know what you
like you know you don't know what that
is why do you think they hold back on
what they really want to do because
they're afraid I think
socialized to to
like want to keep themselves
and this but this good man doesn't
actually exist right they think that if
they hold out and if they just like keep
being this good girl they'll find a guy
that's respectable but in reality this
respectable guy isn't respectable at all
because respectfully if a guy cares
about your sexual history or like all
these other things that don't actually
matter besides your actual human
connection and compatibility then he's
not a respectable guy you know what I
mean like yeah then it's like you are
literally like we're we're like adults
now you know like at this point it's
like we're not 16 17. of course I would
have had sexual experiences before you I
shouldn't be holding out for you because
you didn't hold out for me not so
whether you're pure or not you should
still love me yeah it's more like
also it's it's like your own
insecurities that you should like
acknowledge like if I have that
experiences and that makes you feel bad
why it's like past sexual jealousy yeah
is that what it is like if you're afraid
that I've had all these other sexual
experiences that I may not be faithful
to you or I may not be able to be taken
seriously amongst your peers that's a
personal problem that you have to
acknowledge you know versus like what I
have to do with myself you know because
I'm my own person and if it's also
something that you feel like is a deal
breaker for you then we shouldn't date
you know because I can't change that and
vice versa like there's guys who
intimidate me because they've done so
much but it's like those are my own
insecurities I acknowledge yeah that's
crazy that makes so much sense but we
don't apply it because it's not like we
go to like a dog shelter but man you had
another master I have adopting your ass
you had one already saying it to the dog
yeah you ran through bro
I feel like there is a primal thing in a
man's mind that like is like I want to
make sure that baby is mine so there's
that weird like they can't make sense of
what's going on I think as an animal but
then as a human being we're able to out
think exactly so then when you work on
yourself you could you that sexual
jealousy will disappear yeah and I feel
like people will rationalize their
insecurities and make like enemies and
scapegoats and they'll like have some
weird roundabout reason why they don't
like a girl who's had a large body
counter who's had sex but it really all
just comes down to like you're not
comfortable because you think she just
might know something you don't know and
then she will leave you and that feeling
of Abandonment is like on again your own
personal problem that you should
acknowledge because I've left girls
because
um they
were sexually like relaxed about [ __ ]
like so like they if they can't have
conversations or like they're just like
it's just why why is there so much shame
in you and I feel like we can't connect
and then so I'm just like but I don't
want to feel like the dude pressuring so
this is not a relationship that I want
yeah and then but so that's why it blew
my mind where I'm like why would you
want a girl that's like hidden
about her sexuality and it's not even
just hidden like because you could be
not sexual experienced but know yourself
a lot it's also just like why do you
have so many shameful ideas about sex
like when people ask me what type of guy
I want I say like I like a guy who has a
very healed perspective on women and I
feel like you can tell when a guy has
very traumatic experiences of women like
back when they were younger and they
still carry it to this day and he's like
opinions about sex and like women and
relationships carry with them like there
will be times where like a guy will like
like for example like simping I'm living
is a bad thing if you want to like show
that you're into a girl [ __ ] do it
but if you believe but like when guys
police that are men on simping I'm just
like dude you obviously like wow you
know what's funny is people will talk
[ __ ] about uh like like our group of
guys being simps to the woman that
you're married to or the woman that is
like already you're [ __ ] married you
dumb [ __ ] like how are you a Sim tour
I'm never a Sim I don't ever well you
could like appreciate people like I
forgot your name but I said for this guy
I like this guy yeah super disco for all
of you guys you know but it's like it's
not like a demeaning thing to be into it
also I feel like a lot of men won't
Express that they want you and I feel
like I look out for that too if a guy if
I feel like a guy doesn't want to be
like give me those verbal affirmations I
don't play games I have like a busy ass
woman you know so I want to know that
this is what you want to do and if you
feel embarrassed about it like the last
I like went on a date with a normal guy
he wouldn't kiss me and I was like this
why literally stupid that's not what the
pickup artist taught him bro
wait wait so he'll [ __ ] you but he won't
kick all like yeah really stupid so you
don't like it when someone feels icky
toward you but they like you was he like
this
he was like
yeah and it's like you could have your
own bounties maybe maybe he doesn't kiss
any girl I don't know maybe yeah but
maybe I don't know [ __ ] is he agitate or
something can I have sex without kissing
I just feel like that's like one of like
the things that we do like as we go down
the line of like [ __ ] that we want to do
to each other order of operation do you
believe uh in a sex Edition like can
someone be addicted to it I think
anything like in like super excess can
be like bad for you but I also feel like
the intent is important because
obviously I have a lot of sex but I also
like I'm not trying to fulfill a void or
a race like a part of myself or like I
like just do it because it's fun if it's
in a Controlled Chaos way I feel like
it's fine to enjoy sex and explore it
but like let's say like I just couldn't
do this podcast because I had to [ __ ]
someone right now
podcast is important for me to do you
know it's like this because it's
destructive behaviors do you feel like
your life would be way more focused if
you never had to nut like do you feel
like you would just accomplish way more
if you never just have more time if I
didn't have the feeling probably if you
never had to think about getting laid
like you would just be like yeah
probably I think I think I definitely uh
like uh weathered or like uh hindered
some of my uh drive because I've got
I've been so like sex driven and like
more interested and wanted to like go
and go find a shorty go get her like
that 23 bro but what I'm saying
being creative and doing something I
wouldn't really just thinking about
[ __ ] I was just like that's when I
was jacking off the most me too if I
could not think about sex I might be in
the Olympics or something I might be
like to be fair I probably gave me some
drive like I think I started dancing for
girls yeah but you know what though I
kind of get it because when you come you
just go take a nap and you waste three
more hours of your time and you wake up
again you jack off again and that's
another three hours the whole day just
[ __ ] just masturbating jacking off
and I'll just masturbate again and then
you call girl over yeah and even though
he [ __ ] came twice you [ __ ] again
just because she's older this is your
personal experience but yeah do you feel
like your whole life your whole lives
are centered around getting laid in some
way shape or form like like
subconsciously yeah consciously it's
like I do this podcast and now I get
[ __ ] yeah like uh in the past I believe
when I was like all the way up until my
20s all the things I did I can't wait to
meet girls now it's like I do is podcast
I hope I get paid if I can keep the roof
that maybe the [ __ ] will stay
it's like
let me do these things and then
hopefully like I'm just able to keep
fulfilling and funding my horny
lifestyle
but that's just because of my life not
because it's a prerogative yeah because
you're like doing it yeah yeah that's
the question because you've obviously
experienced like a very wide palette of
things sexually and stuff like are there
still fantasies or desires that you have
not fulfilled I feel like for me I like
a good story so I feel like I've done
like I've directed and I've like decided
creatively done projects where I've been
like let's do this like it'd be hot if
you did this to me and then did this to
me but like now it's like I like just
meeting people and seeing how it falls
into me like when I was at that swingers
resort I was just meeting people and
like I like seeing like the storyline of
how is how was the first time we're
gonna kiss how was the first time like
like it's like you're talking at what
point are you gonna like start fingering
me like that's like sexy thing she's an
organic flow like the real experience I
really like the initial experience
because it's like the foreplay I can
make any sexual fantasy of mine happen
and I can get paid for it but it's like
it's those like real life moments that I
feel like I really Chase because
unscripted it's more novel because it's
like what the [ __ ] was that it's like oh
my God like because it's like for me
it's like I schedule having sex with you
I get tested every seven to ten days oh
you show me your test it's too
controlled yeah I show you you we booked
the photography booked the hotel room
and then we know that at 7 pm dick is
like you put it on the table it's here
where it's like I'm late yeah I played
guys and then at 7 30
the ejaculation is due right now right
now damn that's a lot of pressure wow
yeah yeah that's too scary don't make it
705 yeah I feel like it's fun because
obviously it's not that structured it's
like it's like we'll start we'll meet at
four and then it'll just go on and then
we'll eat after and it's fun but it's
again it's controlled and it's like also
because I get tested so much and I work
so much I don't have outside sex because
I wouldn't want to have sex with an
outsider and then like risk bringing
something back into the pool a lot of
porn performers really don't like that
when you [ __ ] outside the industry yeah
I've seen this yeah yeah so it's like
it's kind of like it is time because
they're probably nastier outside the
industry because they're all trying to
maintain like a safe ecosystem let's
just think about it like an STD takes
about five to seven days to incubate
right so let's say like I you give me
chlamydia I get tested I [ __ ] him
tomorrow I have a clean test then the
next day you get chlamydia and then it's
like I [ __ ] this it's just like you know
so it's like we have to be super
controlled so when I want to [ __ ] a guy
it's like I lose the spontaneity of when
I was 22 23 where it's just like let's
just [ __ ] and I'm like hey we hear my
first of all my boyfriend's boundaries
and then second of all I need you to get
tested and then for first time we would
[ __ ] I would not want to have raw sex
with you because I don't [ __ ] know
you and then after a few times and you'd
still have to get tested on top of that
and for me like testing is like 300 400
bucks to get it the next day wow yeah
that's how much it costs for a next day
result yeah well like companies will pay
for it but you're an average guy you
know so it's like who actually gets
tested every five mine's actually above
average it like needs the result yeah
you're like I'm above average yeah the
average person does not know who I am
that makes it surgical dude have you
ever met anybody that just like oh my
test right here like a covet test
I mean if I'm like at a sex club then
I'll have condom sex you know and I just
won't suck any dick because I won't have
I Won't Suck condom dick that's like
that's a hate crime will you were you
more straight up
coffee mug yeah so during coven were you
like man I got a [ __ ] test for this
and kovid and make sure I don't get
covered from your [ __ ] ass yeah so
right now for porn performers we do the
whole STD panel which is blood and urine
plus the throat swab plus the anal swab
even if I I don't do anal like you could
be eating me out and a spit could drift
down to my butthole so it's good to just
get tested for all of it so the cost for
that is extremely expensive but luckily
I work enough that the return of
investment is fine but the average small
performer is probably like what the [ __ ]
like you know I'm paying to work but
it's also like you're paying for your
safety and making sure we don't die
because right we evolve like and it's
also assuming that you're [ __ ] that
much like you know I'm not [ __ ] every
single day on this 14 day test that's
crazy you know like I'm probably [ __ ]
like maybe four times on this success
and it's just for the peace of mind like
that we're good yeah
with the same performer so you can make
more content right I usually try to have
a variety and I like the first time I
[ __ ] someone and I like finding like the
style and the variety in your experience
do you have your rankings of dues
whether it be by uh whatever demographic
ethnic or whatever Johnny Sins was bomb
bro wow dude Johnny's my my scene of
Johnny since actually got nominated for
an Avian Award and it was just us in
like an Airbnb and like a tripod what
was that that was on only fans yeah yeah
so I always I'm like how the [ __ ] dude
he's a good [ __ ] yeah but I was like
how the [ __ ] do they judge that like is
there like a guy that just goons in the
cave and this is like watches like 15
porns and he's like that was a good one
yeah how do they do that I don't know
how they judged it like they they
nominated me no I'm saying how do you
judge it like like he was a good [ __ ]
like what what made him versus they're
like I once asked Isaiah Maxwell I was
like what makes
or make what makes a good performer
specifically because I was caring about
my performance not so much the sex and
he was like it's everything to do with
before after and during like not
necessarily the penetrative part but
establishing that Sexual Energy and
chemistry of like this is like like
we're having an organic connection even
though we're getting paid and this is
like orgasm yeah and then with Johnny
Sins it's like he was saying there's
only like five positions there's
missionary doggy cowgirl reverse cowgirl
maybe spooning but it's like how do you
make it more interesting it's like
making the leg a little bit higher it's
like adjusting her a little bit more
it's a small things that make it like
yeah he got the details like we had like
missionary for like like we had
missionary 20 different times but it was
always a different type of missionary so
it's just like understanding those
details and being purposeful with sex
yeah duly noted since so since you
[ __ ] so many sex birds out there like
like I mean you've had
a lot of like really good performers
right
and then so like when you go back to
your boyfriend
um how's that experience like I feel
like
when you hang out with Bart do you like
compare it with hanging out with this
guy big time Bart's way more fun it's
okay no no it's okay it's okay not a
name thing well it's way more fun and
Bart will actually suck dick too so yes
I will yeah but it's just like like if I
get dinner with my friend I don't
compare that dinner to my other friend
that's a completely different experience
you know so the same thing I get what
you mean though yeah you [ __ ]
like hey no you're right though cause
he'll go golfing with me and embar will
go shooting with me yeah so it's like
different different type of Friends
Church friends versus Club friends from
the vibe like some guy some people are
like really sensual and that's what I
want and then some guys like it's just
like like it's like destruction it's
personal but with my boyfriend it's like
we have this history of understanding
and we know what we like already we have
our routine and it feels familiar and
it's like and it's like there's also
this connection like I love this person
and he loves me and I feel safe whereas
like you know it's just a different
experience like I like sometimes I'll
have normal sex of other guys and I used
to be scared like what's the point like
it might suck but it's like if the
chemistry is there you you understand
each other so it's fine yeah how how is
it when you come home after having sex
with another person coming home to your
dude like how is that like all you had
to do the beetle get like shortened or
because you're satisfied already or I
mean I would say naturally if I'm
[ __ ] and I come home that's like I'm
still coming home from a day of work you
know like I'm coming home from doing a
podcast like this then I'll probably get
lunch with a friend and I'll probably do
my scene I come home that's still like a
lot of emotional and mental labor so
it's me coming home from work so I'm
tired you know so like me coming home
from work I'll I'll probably be tired I
could still be up for sex but I'd
probably rather like focus on different
parts of intimacy like cuddling and like
talking about my day and actually just
like putting my hair down taking off my
lash extensions and feeling like safe of
somebody which is more intimate than sex
in my opinion you know because most
people don't see me as like like that
because I'm no longer Kazumi I'm my real
name which is redacted and it has it has
it been that has it been that way like
what's your man being like hey what's up
man like how'd it go like is it does it
does it have the combo or y'all just
don't I'm a depraved girl you know like
when he [ __ ] other girls I want to know
every detail I want a little position I
want to know where you came with him if
I'm like yeah and then he put me on the
he'll be like no no like I just want to
know you did it did you have a good time
I'll tell him like funny stories like
I'll tell him like oh my God like this
[ __ ] was trash bro like all right or
I'll tell him if like something like
silly happened or like some like
conversations are happening but I
wouldn't like go detail by detail like
yeah I was sending this day again
that's why I wouldn't know like
I'm still the man overnight like this
was this happened over the course of
three years you know we were we built a
really strong Foundation of like our
relationship that was just us and then
over time I remember we found my friend
who's also Filipino and her boyfriend
was also black and we did a couple swap
and it felt really comfortable because I
knew my homegirl loved her boyfriend and
I knew my boyfriend loved me so when he
[ __ ] her I was like oh so it didn't
start open it was like you built the
interface you you built the trust we
worked towards it like it wasn't just
like we start like when we started
dating I was already a [ __ ] girl I
already had an only fans I already did
these sex parties and [ __ ] and I was he
was curious about it and then but I
wasn't but we had to build our
relationship first and then once our
relationship was built that's when we
were like let's try this let's go to a
sex party and just [ __ ] each other let's
go couple swap and eventually it became
like threesomes and now we can I can do
like individual dating and stuff but
that took a long time yeah okay gotcha
we are at the uh overtime part but you
know there's a classic question that
yeah we asked one question yeah
just kind of
um the caterpillar one
yeah I'll turn it to Wagon uh would you
rather [ __ ] your mom or your dad what
um I was never asked that then we'll
bring you back on we'll bring it yeah
don't worry everyone answers everybody
answers no you did answer this whatever
[ __ ] my mom or my dad I feel like I'd
rather [ __ ] my mom because he wouldn't
be [ __ ] really we would just be like
oh that's cheating then yeah
all right you'd have to strap on and
then [ __ ] your mom or she has to strap
on and [ __ ] you yeah
if she's strapon [ __ ] me doggy style I
could close my eyes and just imagine
like my boyfriend or something I could
imagine you can't mentally Escape that's
not fair like Rob Piper oh really please
thank you for participating did she
answered she did answer that's a good
answer between us so we're basically not
even touching she's just dry humping
that's all right [ __ ] eye to eye
intimate sex
20 different missionaries like this with
her and you're just like oh like we're
like boy that's a foreign
she's a horny girl and um I met her at
this Asian collab party so like what
happens is a lot of only fans girls back
in the day we would meet like on these
like group chats and [ __ ] and we'd be
like yo let's get a mansion for a
weekend I'll split it 10 people and
let's just just work for three for like
a weekend straight so like a writer's
Retreat yeah
like Cher will have the tripod
I met this woman
and then we would party at night it
would be awesome but it'd be like yo we
just had a bunch of orgies you know and
now it's like now we're at like x-pot
you know and like this woman she just
looked like my mom bro and I was like
bro it'd be funny it'd be so funny if we
did a scene where you [ __ ] my
boyfriend and I got fake mad about it
I always I'm like what if my mom saw
that she'd be like what the [ __ ] dude
why didn't you invite me
your mom is all like that should have
been me
like my like she's a realistic figma
I'll show you in a second all right all
right nice and you guys have to
subscribe if you want to see the fake
mom
[Music]
foreign